immediately would uh
in in my head i'd be like okay never
this is it
pete davidson dishes on his dating deal
breaker amid rumors he's dating kim
kardashian i don't know where these
rumors come from the 28 year old
comedian who's previously been linked to
stars like ariana grande and kate
beckinsale appeared on iheart media's
river cafe table 4 podcast and opened up
to host and celebrity chef ruth rogers
about one thing he's definitely not okay
with on a first date i suppose if you
went to a restaurant and and your date
was rude to the waiter or was you know
then that would be over wouldn't it
would you ever
immediately would uh
in my head i'd be like okay never this
is it
the saturday night live star also shared
another dating faux pas he isn't down
with i don't like the excuse me it's
like wait for the guy to walk by and
then just lightly be like i think that
also people who have worked in a
restaurant
it teaches you something doesn't it the
best lessons i've learned have been from
working in that restaurant like learning
how to work with people learning how to
act around certain people that don't
like you and after all that pete
explained why he prefers dinner dates to
any other kind of date if you go to a
great restaurant like even if i'm a
date
it's like at least the food was great
you know so like she could go home and
be like
you know he paid of course earlier this
month a source told et that pete and kim
kardashian had dinner together in staten
island at italian restaurant campania
pete is from staten island and back in
2019 he told paper magazine that
campania is one of his favorite spots
and a source previously told et that the
actor and the kkw beauty founder are
taking things slow we'll just have to
wait and see quote kim and pete are
casually dating and seeing where things
go pete is really into kim and excited
about her kim likes pete as well but
isn't rushing into anything serious
on monday night etie caught up with
pete's snl co-star alex moffatt when
asked about rumors that his buddy may be
dating kim he played coy
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend uh pete's up to i
just hope he's vaccinated as long as
he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love meanwhile
emily radakowski who recently did a
photo shoot with pete told seth meyers
on his late night show why she thinks
women are so drawn to the funny guy i'm
only he's got the height he is a tall
obviously women find him very attractive
you guys are like wow what's that guy
got and i'm like i mean he seems super
charming he's vulnerable he's lovely
great his finger nail polish is awesome
like he looks good there you go that's
great all right well i'm sold i'm gonna
have him back on good relationship with
his mother yeah great relationship with
his mother we love it